MIKE WOLFE: This is Model A
Firetruck.
VANESSA: Right.
MIKE WOLFE: Wow.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER): We're
here in Indiana with Vanessa
and her daughter, Savannah.
Vanessa's father was
the Model A king,
and now she's carrying
on his legacy.
FRANK FRITZ: What's top
speed in a car like this?
VANESSA: 55.
FRANK FRITZ: I bet
it gets the looks.
VANESSA: Oh, it does.
It's almost a Bonnie and Clyde
car, only a little bit earlier.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER): Out
of all the Model A's that
have passed through
Bill's hands,
these are the ones
that he held onto.
Look at this, Frankie.
FRANK FRITZ: Oh, that's nice.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
He kept the rare,
the unusual, the different.
I love this kind of stuff.
VANESSA: This is made in Canada.
It has a 29 cowl,
but it is a 30.
MIKE WOLFE: 30.
What's so special
about this one
is this carriage company
may have made more,
but I feel like it's the
only one that has survived.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER): Another
one of Bill's crown jewels
in the collection is
a truck from Canada.
The body was modified
by a carriage company,
and as far as Vanessa
knows, it's the only one.
What do you value this car at?
I'd like to get
$35,000 out of it.
I can kind of set my
own price because it's
the only one that exists.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER): Vanessa
feels this truck is so rare
that she can set her own price.
There's nothing
to compare it to.
MIKE WOLFE: It's beautiful.
This truck right here,
we got some history.
This is my pouting truck.
What do you mean
by pouting truck?
Oh, me and mom, you
know, our little spats.
Mother, daughter.
When you get your
way or something?
When I didn't get my way and
it was too cold to walk out
to the horse barn, I would
just come to this truck
right here, because it
was super comfortable.
Sit in the truck--
Did you know
that's where she was?
Cross my little
arms, and work it out.
I mean, we had
conversations, me and you,
and you weren't even in there.
It still happens.
I couldn't help but
notice the Texaco sign.
VANESSA: Great for a single
decoration on the wall.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER): Texaco
was one of the top-tier names
for Petroliana collectors.
Made in 1948.
It's double-sided.
I mean, it is porcelain.
It will clean up.
The only thing bad that
it's got going for it
is whoever mounted it has
these big creases in it.
VANESSA: Yeah.
FRANK FRITZ: I mean,
that's the, I don't
want to say the kiss
of death, but that's
the bad part about it.
- Yeah.
How about $650?
Six and 1/4.
It's yours.
- Six and 1/4?
- Yeah.
All right.
Good deal.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
it takes a little longer
to move these bigger
signs, but even
with the damage
and the creases, I
can still make a little money.
I just discovered
I had a 29 back half.
I got 29 doors.
And I have a 29 cowl
in another barn,
that I can make a
29 roadster pickup.
I love that you know
what everything is.
Somebody had told me I was
going to do this for a living
when I was 16.
No way.
I was a hairdresser.
OK.
Hairdressers, Model A, right?
MIKE WOLFE
(VOICEOVER): Vanessa is
such a strong, beautiful woman.
And over the years,
she was determined
to make it on her own and
honor her father along the way.
Your dad would be
really proud of you.
Yes.
Just getting to know him, and
doing the business with him,
and seeing how he
would wheel and deal,
and I wouldn't give anything
for that experience.
Let's go see if
we can find Frank.
He's probably getting
in some trouble.
I don't trust him with
Savannah by himself.
SAVANNAH: Frank, I want
to show you my car.
FRANK FRITZ: All right.
This is my 1931.
This is your car?
A400.
FRANK FRITZ: Wow, this is nice.
Yeah, she's very special.
That's why she's in the back.
In the back, nobody
can touch her.
We got to keep her special.
That's right.
VANESSA (VOICEOVER):
My dad wanted
to make sure each of the kids
inherited some kind of Model A.
FRANK FRITZ: What's
the plans on this here?
I'm going to sell it.
I would really like to be
able to take the money,
and take care of my
family, and have a home.
So you want to buy a house?
SAVANNAH: Yeah I
want to buy a house.
I want to buy some land.
Good for you.
I'm hoping it will
help me pay off college,
and kids, and property.
Frank, take a peek
into my world.
I'm looking at your
world right here.
I can see why you are
selling so much in your booth.
VANESSA: Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
Savannah is very persuasive.
Just imagine her all
shined up and those seats,
I could almost pout
in those seats too.
But I don't think he's
going to buy this car.
A guy in Alabama
offered my dad,
right before he
passed away, $110,000
for that one and this one.
And dad in the hospital,
sitting, he said, Vanessa, I
should have taken that.
FRANK FRITZ: What were
you thinking on it?
I wanted 50, but 45?
- $45,000?
- Cash.
Money.
Well, that's the only way
to go is that cash money.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
I really appreciate
her showing me the car.
I've never seen one like it.
But today, I'm not a player.